dude I want to [__] kiss you on the
lips you wearing underwear huh I see
women come up to him they kiss him on
the cheek they want to hug him they want
to flirt with him say hey come with us
have drinks and stuff he's a cute
talented man why wouldn't they be
attracted to him I'm attracted to him
right I got into an Uber and the driver
he's like I recognized you from hot ones
my mouth got kind of burnt out around
the edges looked like I'd been trying to
[__] French kiss a candle I had a lot
of different colors around my mouth I
was starting to really Roy G Biv around
the lips just to see somebody say
goodbye to someone to see somebody give
a kiss to somebody oh wow that's human
interaction that's connection turn on
some Netflix maybe watch [__] always
be my maybe and then afterwards or in
the middle you know what I mean because
you know when you're watching the
Netflix or do you keep going no you keep
it going oh wow yeah you can pause it no
you don't though think about think about
if you're with a chick you don't pause
it I pause it and let her know that's a
boss move wow you're an alpha am I oh
hey bro hey my bro think about that [__]
you're watching a movie with a chick
you're watching you just go boom
yeah that's amazing bro I don't pause it
I'm you know why I'm too scared that's
actually a good move because then it's
like you're like I'm pausing this
because I want to kiss you but just so
you know I want to get back to this
movie afterwards you're not that
important for me to miss this movie yeah
who knows
you know I remember I only saw my father
kiss my mother one time and it was on
the top of her head it was her birthday
he kissed from the top of the head and I
just remember seeing my mom just be
disappointed do people ever think you're
Brad Pitt if anybody ever come up to you
and thought you were Brad Pitt a kid did
the other day yeah he literally is like
about 80 goes were you in World War Z
I go
no but I want to kiss you I remember I
saw a couple middle schoolers making out
one time when I was driving two young
boys dude I pulled over I said hey guys
give it two years and see what's up
these boys were 11 and they were kissing
out there and it's fine but sometimes
the children can just get easily
influenced you know some animals pass
gas on each other the Japanese do it you
go to Japan do you fart somewhere have
two people come over and they'll hug you
different places it's a different thing
so every time he does it maybe you give
him a big wet kiss I had another lady in
the same town grab my junk and come in
and grab me and kiss me and I had
literally I was married at that time so
I you know he said hey well even if I
wasn't right get off me pay me my money
let me go right let me go what if it
don't work out say this girl kisses me
and I throw her on the floor and just
ravage her and we have a great time yeah
and then I don't call her back and now
she calls my company I know you have a
line in one of your songs that's like
incest I just kiss sister yeah something
yeah yeah there's stories behind all
that [__] I was thinking this week about
kissing you know when you kiss somebody
kissing is when you put your mouth
against somebody else I could only
imagine the first time somebody said hey
let me know if you feel anything about
this and then they just did it somebody
said hey let me just put my mouth
against your face or something or your
neck bruh and see if you feel something
some dude probably started trying on his
buddy who was nervous like hey let me
try it on you a couple times and then
I'll run over there to Dorothy you know
so some guy maybe had a real nice friend
and he let him try that let him just try
that pack sprinkling that pecoroni all
over him just kind of nibbling on his
neck because you had to practice
somewhere you had to practice kissing
nobody goes right out there first time
and just drops that face onto somebody
else what who you Ted Bundy dude you
can't do you gotta practice dude I
remember when I was young we would get
like a pillow my buddy Patrick he would
come over and we would get these pillows
dude and we would lay next to him and
just be like erotic you know and my body
would get so hard right in the middle
dude God I just didn't know what was
going on and I didn't know that the
devil and God were just fighting inside
of my penis at the time and the first
time we were supposed to just be kissing
our pillows my buddy would lay over my
brother's bed because my brother wasn't
living with us and I would lay on my bed
and we're supposed to just be kissing
our pillows and pretending they were
these girls that we liked but nine
seconds into it dude you know what I'm
saying things have escalated
you know we go on a second base Third
Base fourth base fifth base sixth base
you know then you got Pedro Martinez
beating the [__] out of Tommy Lasorda
you know what I'm talking about boy
Young Bucks just
you know just vibrating against the
pillow man just
dude I could Hotwire one of those you
know those little carousels outside of a
grocery I could Hotwire one of them
[__] with my with the just the
victrosity that was in my damn pecker at
the time my buddy would come over we
would just practice on them but then you
had to do kissing you know and like it
you practice on the pillow but something
wasn't enough and in Louisiana it's an
oyster country certain areas have a
different animal we would practice
kissing man we would get an oyster and
you get it open man and then you got to
get it out of there I always felt bad
taking an oyster out of his little house
man I felt kind of bad about that [__]
we went over to the Presbyterian church
and I told that man I said man we've
been taking these oysters out and
and pretending they were tongues and
kissing them you know I think that
preacher told me I was a piece of [__]
but he also I think he kind of winked at
me a little bit so you know 50 50. throw
that oyster in the microwave for about
11 seconds and get it warm enough put it
in your hand and you can practice the
kissing I mean it wasn't ideal but it
was way better than kissing on your
buddy's neck a little you remember
kissing practice and kissing how'd you
practice hit the hotline let me know how
you practiced kissing we practiced a
couple ways man my one friend and he was
born with some different deficiencies
but he popped through and we put a bunch
of perfume on his neck and then kind of
practice kissing a little bit but not
not gay not like in a gay way
we'd even put a bag over his head and
draw like a woman on the sides of the
bag and you could still smell the
perfume you could practice you know
pretend oh hey Katie or hey Charlotte
hey Regina hey chandries what's up and
then you could practice you know kissing
get that oyster and heat that thing up
in the microwave for 11 seconds and get
that thing tongue temperature
and then you would practice just
[Music]
I remember just laying Outdoors
sometimes thinking about all the women
that probably wanted to have sex with me
I kissed a little woman on the lips yeah
like a couple of years ago made out of
the show beautiful beautiful spirit
Beautiful Soul there's certain rules and
regulations with little people in the
afterlife they have to do certain tasks
the thing is like they all kind of look
alike to me all these little pictures
like I don't know it's all the same to
me well dude I respect them all but I
just you know what I need to respect
them I do I respect them a lot I keep my
distance safely and I respect them all
wow she'll get kissed on this lady will
get cracked open and cleaned out uh I
like her lips yo dude you want to piss
in my hood
I want to go you know dude all right bro
I've been [__] kiss you on the lips
right now what
get on camera what do we do can I do it
no
come on man just go let's go get him
dude if I'm gay I will tell you bro I'm
not just being gay for no reason man
yeah thank God these are these are uh
these are men
wow wow too much
too much too much guys
be good no get that away when you see
people like Carol who's a fool with her
cats she got out there she tried to hug
and kiss them and play with them it all
fell apart that's the normal Story come
in for the kiss Helen's arm goes good
night baby and gives me a kiss and I go
he's [__] faking it he's gonna wait
till I fall asleep and he's gonna do it
and I did not sleep that night and I
woke up I was like I need to not smoke
weed anymore I remember they had a
handicapped guy in our neighbor who's
mentally handicapped and he used to kind
of Kiss everybody a little and nobody
knew how old he was oh really yeah oh
yeah did you do it
I don't remember if I did or not I
probably I think I hugged him or [__]
wrote on his shoulders or something I'm
dancing by Myself and some girls dancing
with some guys and I look over and she
kind of gives me the swoop to pull her
in so I kind of swoop over I'm thinking
smoothly and start grinding up on this
girl and uh it it she she's digging it
you know she's down she she's grinding
up on me and we're dancing and I just
went in for the kiss thinking like you
know next step is trying to make out
with her and she stops me immediately
and goes whoa whoa whoa you are too
sweaty
and truth be told about your mind yes I
probably was too sweaty after that
softball game she is very coveted
conscious we go on a couple dates for
hanging out from a distance we can't
make any physical contacts kiss each
other hug or whatever if you meet
somebody from Canada bro hug them shake
their hand [__] them treat them well
baby feed them massage them garage Umbra
do something for them because they're
good people Hershey Kiss they're kind of
kissing and making out a little bit and
like she's like all over him and she's
acting kind of crazy and she keeps
sanitizing drugs at my place My First
Girlfriend looked like a boy anyway bro
what was his name uh her name was
Susanna and she's very beautiful adult
woman but at the time she had a very
kind of a masculine energy as a child
and is she your first girlfriend
yeah I think she was she used to lift me
up like I would kiss her and she would
lift me up at the [__] bus stop and
like put my legs around her waist it's
like Dirty Dancing [__] I didn't know
what you were supposed to do with girls
and I remember kissing her and stuff and
she was like tomorrow night you can go
up my shirt but the back so when I would
go up the back of her shirt dude she
would make her shoulder blades yeah she
would stick them out so I could feel
them I saw my parents kiss one time at
like a birthday how'd you feel and it
was like my dad like kissed my mom on
the head I remember up here or back here
back here oh standing behind her it was
okay you're like the original woodpecker
like a nightingale yeah anytime you say
I'm an Auctioneer oh really you talk
fast yeah you're a fast driver yeah
and then I'm sure a lot of the ladies
are probably leading them into wanting
to kiss get a little French action you
know a little tongue action is that a do
people want to test drive it a little
we're gonna see tonight oh leatherneck
Sun Bended Knees can kiss the ass of
beauty tees dude if you came out with a
turkey THC that [__] that'll put you to
sleep boy both those things have put me
to sleep if I have a little bit of
turkey or I have a dang hit on a joint
or hit on it now yeah just smell you
right down dab you know hell if I even
kiss some girl that's been smoking dope
I'll [__] go to bed man when you
started getting horny yeah and then
you'd go on a field trip and you'd be
like nice I'm sitting with the girl yeah
yes this is so cool we're gonna kiss
kiss with a fist oh and they don't play
it much anymore with such a good [__]
Banger kissing on them and loving on
them kiss you on the head or tell you he
loved you I like to dwell I like to
wander around in the art museum of my
childhood things that meant something to
me my first kiss [__] Bernie Sanders
there I said it you [__] socialist he
went to the Soviet Union on his
honeymoon
[__] that guy okay that guy's not an
American he's a communist so kiss my ass
[__] yeah why do I want to
support you you haven't been supporting
me so kiss my ass you guys be good to
yourselves man and let's take it out of
here with a little bit of Bishop again
[Music]
do you say I do
yes and you see how I do you may now
kiss the bride
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could I be so far from my
oh yeah man
and my mind is somewhere else but when I
find it I'll patch up where it's been
grown
[Music]
oh but when I reach that round out I'll
share this piece of my life found I can
feel it in my bones
but it's gonna take
time
for me to sell that parking braid and
let myself
[Music]
foreign
man check your wife check your spouse
for babies everybody check your lady for
a damn baby that ain't a mole that might
be a baby
[Music]
come on now
find a song
all right let's go all the way man
[Music]
I love you
song I will sing it just for you
[Music]